I sent you earlier on a video about Dove
yeah that was great so for the people
that haven't seen it Dove is on a
mission to challenge and change female
representation in video games and help
make gaming a positive space for women
and girls so they've created this video
of like superhero girl superhero and
they she slays this this evil Baddie and
then she gets back into the changing
room and takes her armor off and gains
80 pounds yeah that was odd immediately
and then like sits down puts her hands
behind about and realizes I don't need
to wear the armor that is holding me in
and then she goes out and like keeps on
fighting but now she's 80 pounds bigger
yeah
um
female characters in games do not
accurately represent the diverse Gamers
of the world and are often heavily
sexualized and created within narrow
unrealistic beauty standards 74 of girls
feel unrepresented in video games
um I'm looking forward to the Call of
Duty lizzo skin dropping I want to
unlock I want to unlock lizzo too big of
a target a terrorist it's too easy but
here's why a couple things I love the
idea of the animator being like the
director's like we need her fatter so
he's like oh [__] all right so he has to
make her bigger but also
I get it look it's all I'm all about
helping women and having them being
represented but aren't we
going it's it's getting hacky now like
Miller Lite Bud Light all the uh
Starbucks had a big commercial with the
Trans and you're like well now it's just
hacked the whole thing with the
marketing and and uh stuff like this
like this kind of art you gotta go a new
way isn't that the whole point of uh
being original like
when they Zig you zag and they're all
zagging everybody's going in the same
direction yeah so I'm like to me it's
not even about the the woke [__] or
whatever you want to call it it's like
you're just being unoriginal now it's
boring it's boring I think the main
concern that people unpredictable it's
kind of the same as the uh like Supply
demand problem for racism which is it
doesn't seem genuine yes it's forced
yeah completely Forest completely uh
what do you call that uh
starts with a C contrived thank you you
nailed it [__] yeah wow Captain what's
happening together periods are saying
that's menstrual cycle exactly
um
so yeah I think it's just that people
don't believe that this is is this
actually coming from a place of genuine
sympathy or is this coming from what's
it called walk washing yeah yes Madison
Avenue yeah I learned uh what was the
[__] thing work washing is allowing
Brands to monetize virtue signaling it
conceals the less altruistic business
practices so Miller Lite and Bud Light
you know it's two good examples that you
brought up there
where are they getting their tin from is
anybody looking at the aluminum that
goes into the cans of course not like
looking at the production processes are
they meeting sanitation standards are
they doing all the rest of it and it's
like no but they gave Dylan Mulvaney six
a six-pack with her face on it that's
like enough to look over there look over
there you don't need to look over here
yes yes and I think with the dove maybe
actually does feel a little bit like um
a company that for a long time has been
fighting for different beauty standards
they've been stuck with skin that's true
like trying to get representation for
different girls but if you're gonna
fight the good fight it doesn't feel
like video games are the place that
girls are looking yes find their
representation exactly and they there
was no soap in that commercial there was
not one bar of soap not a ladder not a
lotion nothing yeah exactly it was just
video gaming and I'm like I don't know
it's also weird that we have to shoehorn
women sure there are women Gamers I'm
sure but like it doesn't feel like
that's their their big uh demo is these
these fat ladies like like advertise on
uh Vanderpump Rules like every lady I
know my wife included has like six girls
over they're all watching it I walk in
they're like shh
exactly exactly but she's not there
which is also probably why it's doing
well you know it goes back to the Barbie
it's like Barbie's unrealistic and I'm
like yeah yeah but who wants a realistic
toy you know but women think they're
gonna think they have to look like that
I'm like
maybe they want to look like that or
maybe you know uh that's that's okay if
you wanna like I every superhero I had
was jacked I don't want a fat superhero
well I'm not jacked someone so I put
this out on Twitter earlier on and
someone replied and said
um
they can't wait for a version of Kratos
you know from God of War are you
familiar with that guy it's like just
like a jacked God God figure type guy
can't wait for uh skinny fat Kratos or
um Solid Snake right uh to be creeping
around but he's lost a foot due to
diabetes
I don't know just there seems to me if
you need if you're so narcissistic that
you need direct representation yeah in
your avatar in a computer game there are
bigger problems than Simply Having a
fuller figured Avatar are going to be
able to fix yes completely and
it's just human nature we like to look
at attractive things I mean every
president who won has been taller every
I think maybe except for one but it's
always a taller guy who wins full head
of hair helps yeah yeah I mean it's it's
in men too like we we want our men
looking the right way as well what was
that was it Nixon did he do some famous
uh debate yes he was one of them was
sweaty and the other one wasn't sweaty
he did one on radio and one against
Kennedy because she couldn't see how
good-looking Kennedy was and then when
they were at TV aired it Kennedy won
that pretty privilege man yeah I don't
know I I think it's just
it's such a shame that you have
conversations that get captured by
like there are much longer levers than
trying to fix yes whether or not girls
are being misrepresented in video games
exactly and uh let's talk to the ladies
see what they think also it just first
of all It Feels So forced but oh I
forgot my point you said something say
it say what you said again maybe it'll
jog it that it oh I got it back thank
you that's all I needed was your sweet
sweet in uh English voice so oh I lost
it again say it again start talking
oh I got it
I got was real but uh you mentioned the
the tin can where's that coming from and
then like here's a perfect example
Kaepernick everybody's blowing
Kaepernick he's kneeling he hates police
I get it
Nike the biggest example of all
sweatshops you know we need the Asian
fingers to make the shoes and all that
and you can Overlook that because you're
looking at the guy with the afro who's
got the fist up and you go hey I'm a
good person but when you say to people
well what about the Sweatshop people
they go ah and you're like no no you're
not allowed to go ahead me with the
Sweatshop and like Kaepernick you have
to if you're such a morally good person
in Superior correct you have to agree to
both but they just they just shut one
out and that's where I get pissed well
hypocrisy is just like the perfect uh
tool that people want to point out on
the internet right because For the First
Time Ever we have this
um locked in stone history of every
single thing that we've said precisely
as we said it at the times that we said
it and it allows you to say well hang on
you you're making this point now but I
can see that that's not exactly aligned
with what you used to say previously
right so one of my smart Friends the one
that taught me about concept creep he
also taught me that in the modern world
our opinions and our Deeds have never
been further apart in the past any
opinion and any deed would have ended up
being stress tested at some point if you
say that you're a good person and 20 000
years ago around the campfire and yet
every time you go hunting you don't
bring back meat for everybody else you
just bring it for your family eventually
someone's gonna go well come on you keep
you keep saying that you're a good
person right whereas on Twitter no one
ever actually ends up scrutinizing the
way that you show up in the real world
you can be the most empathetic Pro
female person in the world when you go
home beat your wife yes and nobody knows
well for the most part nobody knows and
then when people get rumbled for it
that's why it feels so satisfying to us
yes I think that it's because we have
this sense that a lot of the people who
push virtual real virtual beauty or push
digital blackface is something that
should genuinely be cared about are just
doing performative empathy I don't think
that we believe that it's true
completely right but the pro problem
with the empathy is like when you're on
the other side of it like let's say
you're Ellen who you know big and her
thing is like well you said because she
was the happy Dancy nice lady and then
when we found out she was a Coos
everybody flipped on her because she was
performing uh but the problem is Ellen
could be like well I donate a million
dollars a charity I do all this I help
the homeless I help old people but we
just know about the thing yes so you
don't get that redeeming part and we
love Sam Harris had a great point he
said if if the first time you hear about
somebody is when they've done something
wrong maybe don't jump to hate him
that's the first thing you've heard
about them
what about all the other good [__] they
did but we don't care about that we just
go oh uh Michael J fox said [__] in 88
I've never heard of this guy like if
you're some young person I've never
heard of Michael J fox I hate him now
and you're like you hate him now because
you heard one thing about him on the in
a headline but you just
you totally disregard his whole other
life it's crazy
it's a shame that
we
sort of jump to conclusions so quickly
and this difference between opinions and
deeds the fact that you're able to
behave in one way and say a different
thing and people will care about what
you say more than what you do because
yeah you do is never seen exactly but it
also means that when you do try and
actually put some empathy across that
gets scrutinized too oh well maybe
you're just doing this because no I
genuinely care I care about this
movement or I care about this group of
people This Is Me Being Earnest or or
vulnerable or open and not for some
perverse reason I'm doing this because I
actually care about a thing yeah and
immediately people use the same uh idea
the methodology the skepticism they have
about all the other [__] from all of the
other people that have been doing the
concept creep Supply demand [__] and
then they apply to you and you go well
I'd like and I think that
disincentivizes people completely
genuine completely like altruism as well
I agree yeah it's it's a it's a tough
time makes people just not want to do
anything and just hang back so they
don't get yelled at what's happening
people if you enjoyed that then press
here for the full unedited episode and
don't forget to subscribe
peace